let's go girls
this is every girl's and guys playground
in here that's right this is Fiona by
the way Fiona this is gonna she has her
own name because she's very Grand Aaron
takes a whole lot of space I hear this
is 4 000 yards of threat thread all this
tooling is all hand layered
and how it's just so gorgeous
[Music]
Man I Feel Like a Woman you end the show
with a bang
I love the magic fashion whenever I
work with the designer they always have
to be open to allowing me to read
either structure or redesign certain
things so it's very very custom
how would you describe your time in
Vegas
it's very diverse
it's not just all about the show I get
to live a real lifestyle here out in the
desert I love the restaurants but I
don't have show nights I love taking in
other shows like Katy Perry
how emotional is saying goodbye to this
residency
that's I
have a lot of mixed feelings about it I
I will miss it
all I can do is plan to come back are
there plans to return to Sin City we
don't have any plans right now so
um
we just have to go with the flow and
you know see how things work for now the
five-time Grammy winner has been working
on new music her new single waking up
dreaming is out now
about the tempo it's it's like it's
engraved in my brain
I had so much fun making this album I
enjoy
dreaming I enjoy getting lost in my
dreams and
escaping in them day or night so I wrote
this song about listen when you wake up
all the Dream Begins let it happen so
when I think about a new tour coming up
and I think about getting up there with
new uh music
I really do want it to be music that
will slip in with my other Kick-Ass
music
what do we have to do to get you and
Harry Styles to do an official duet
I know we just have to ask I haven't
ever asked him so I expect him to say
yes Shania who is the best-selling
female country artist of all time has
had her share of personal struggles
including an abusive childhood a battle
with Lyme disease and a very public
divorce which she opens up about in the
Netflix documentary not just a girl out
now I wanted to share things that I knew
that other people may not know about me
that would make it interesting how did
music heal you through those Darkest
Hours well you know music healing me has
come right from the very beginning in my
childhood when I needed to escape
um there's no dinner in the house I'm
hungry
I I gotta I gotta change my Minds Mind
Over Matter grab my guitar go out in the
bush and just write music till it's time
for bed if there was violence in the
house same thing music was that escape
[Music]
when will you know it's time to take a
step back away from music there has
always been a time for change I'm too
energetic to be idle from being creative
there's always something I've never done
before
what is on the bucket list for Shania
Twain I constantly dream of a Las Vegas
equestrian spectacle all with Shania
Twain music
and me and horses
[Music]